what's going on here now one we were
suggested you can solve this question
exactly the same way we solved this
question but it's going to be hard doing
it by cases is going to be very
difficult just lead for a second why why
is it going to be so difficult
okay something new I suggest okay what I
think about cases was so nice and simple
to say well this thing only has two
versions so therefore the whole thing
only has two versions this time I'm
going to have more surprisingly though
you don't actually have four versions
even though each can have to let me show
you why hello look at this we just dealt
with this it's the same one do you
notice that so this is one of two things
based on where does change what is it
switch over on there negative one okay
so there's a version of this to the left
of negative one and then there's a
version of this to the right of negative
one you're great
okay this one what is this basis we
Chobot can you work it out without
writing it all down it's gonna switch
over to you save a city that turns a big
one okay so there's a version of this
when X is less than 2 and then there's
another version of this when X is
greater than 2
do you agree I can't discern a think
about this right if I'm X is next there
negative 1 right I'm going to have the
left version of this which version of
this am I gonna have I'm gonna have the
left version the left version and the
left I'm just gonna write a net net then
I cross over and pass by negative 1 what
happens this guy it switches over to
become the right version but say I was
like at x equals 0
yeah
look at this one which version am I
using right now I'm still using the left
version other and passed by two so he
hasn't changed
do you agree and then lastly I'm
replaced by X equals two
this one was already switched over to
the white version and then this guy
joins you so there are actually three
different portions branches to this
graph okay we can draw so back to then
this time make it decently sized
definitely bigger than this
now by the way unlike this guy over here
do you notice I am NOT drawing the
bottom of this graph my question to you
is how did I know this one wouldn't need
the bottom whereas I looked over here I
thought I think I will
what do you reckon what's the clue in
the question yeah any aha so see that
guy right you're adding things and
importantly this is going to be positive
and so is this you have two positive
things I don't care which positive
things they are they will stay positive
on the other hand or this guy will be
out
there's no problems with being negative
okay and eventually he is so that's why
look carefully before you start to throw
your attitudes and make a document all
right so now I'm gonna have a look I'm
gonna say negative one and then two
now there are two ways that we can
approach this and right now I'm just
going to show you one because otherwise
your brains will melt and if you work
hard enough already
and every quite confusing makes you wise
okay so I'm going to do this now that I
know I'm gonna do this with these cases
now that I know what's what so I'm gonna
say when X is less than negative one
okay do you remember how I had my
versions set up here okay so when X is
less than negative one I've got the left
version of this what do you still left
version of this
think it's this isn't it that's the
negative part to the left when you think
about X's is negative and then I need
the negative the left version of this
which is minus that great that's all in
there let's just simplify that that is
minus X minus 1 minus x plus 2 yes can
you click like toast for me minus 2x
plus 1
so over here that's what I'm going to
get minus 2x plus 1
just hold that anyway all right what
about in between negative 1 & 2 what's
gonna happen
do I have the negative version of this
or the positive version he switched over
did you notice that so I can write just
regular old X plus one but I've still
got then they get version this don't I
he hasn't he hasn't switched over yet so
I'm gonna write with - its most expand
and out pops just three right good
France I still function they haven't
admitted it that's a plus the x's cancel
the numbers come together now we've got
our last one when X is greater than two
now at last everything is just the
positive version the white version okay
so I'm going to say y equals x plus one
plus X minus two
hey you happy with that which by the way
doesn't work suspicious
no connection there's two guys they are
exact opposites of each other of course
they are because look you went from left
left to right right that's the negative
versions of both the positive versions
of both no surprise their exact reaction
okay so now we're getting through it and
again you might look at this next pit
that I'm doing it you'd be like what are
we we had to get back wait until next
week and I will show you in period 0
what other methods for reasons that are
currently excludable I'm going to draw
the middle section first
what do you think of my graph it's look
good
pretty accurate just the horizontal line
y equals three okay so that's it now I'm
gonna do the left side
tell me what you know about this video
it's going to be dropping quite steep
isn't it
where's it supposed to hit the Ottawa
answers at one right it's meant to key
it never gets there does it because of
the domain if I track back a little bit
like rise over run this way you're
actually going to intersect watch you do
that this is y equals minus 2x plus 1 if
I had kept it going it would hit the
plus one over there and finishing off
this is exactly why
and you know I can now pose to you any
question I like in terms of an integral
that you like when is this thing less
than or equal to five okay thank you for
your five line it's all simultaneously
find the points of intersection and give
me the domain this is pretty tricky
though like messing about with this
Lukie in all the different cases it was
quite a long time to work out whether
nothing's going wrong which is why on
Monday morning I'll show you that's the
way of doing it it's conceptually better
but it takes a bit more brain work and
lower temperature to actually understand